restrictions hit businesses really hard
over the past year especially small
businesses
government funding did provide some
emergency relief but that's about to
wrap up
and a lot of those businesses still need
more help to survive
bianca holmen is live this morning in
downtown las vegas with some resources
that are available for entrepreneurs
bianca good morning
hey good morning john good morning alex
you know at the top of next month june
1st live music is going to return here
to freedmont street
so that means more foot traffic for
small businesses at container park and
at ferguson's downtown
and they're looking forward for that of
course again helping to recover from
last year
now with tourism on the rise business
owners are hopeful the economy will
bounce back
we spoke with the president of nevada
state bank he says now is the time to
secure long-term financing because of
low interest rates
this could be the chance for
entrepreneurs to create a generational
opportunity
we're working with a lot of small
business clients right now
who previously were leasing their space
and are taking advantage of this low
interest rate environment
to to buy their location and uh
in many cases lowering their overall
costs and when you're a small business
every dollar matters and if you can
lower your cost and
and also invest in an asset
while you're doing so by buying your
location
you know it can it can really be
beneficial
now nevada state bank also has a
diversity lending program
they've widened the credit box to
provide more opportunities to more
people
and it's also encouraged if you're in
need of help to connect with the local
chamber of commerce here in the valley
there's the las vegas
the henderson the urban chamber and also
the latin chamber
and also if you're needing help finding
employees there are the workforce
development
programs all across the valley and
non-profits helping to get people
back to work reporting live from
downtown bianca holman 8 news now